皆さん
アイスクリームは好きですか
逆にアイスクリーム嫌いな人いますか
みんな大好きですよね
僕もアイスクリーム大好きなんです
この美味しそうな写真のアイス実は牛乳も
卵も使わずに植物性の材料だけで作った
豆乳アイスなんです
僕が
妻と2人で作ってます
この写真の私の溜まりにいる可愛い女性が
妻のマーシーです
この美味しそうなバーガーも
これも
このかわいいチーズケーキも
全部動物を使わずに作られた植物性の
食べ物です
最近では研究室で培養された動物を殺さ
ないお肉なんてなもニュースになってまし
たよね
こういった研究者とか生産者とか消費者
たちの努力によって
世界は少しずつグリーンに変わってきてい
ます
このグラフ
uk の1人あたりのお肉の消費量の推移
です
見ての通り右肩下がりですよね
uk においてこの10年でなんと1人
あたりのお肉の消費量は17%も減りまし
た
vegan ベジタリアンの数は2倍以上
増え
人口の5%程度だと発表されました
すごいですよね
世界が変わっていっていることを実感でき
た瞬間でした
私も有給には3年ほど住んでいたんですが
姉ほど vegan friendly な
国には今のところ入ったことがありません
では
次に
世界全体を見てみましょう
こちらのグラフを見てみてください
この一直線に増加しているもの
これは世界全体でのお肉の消費量の推移
です
私たちは
この50年で
4倍ものお肉を消費するようになりました
ちなみに日本ではこの50年で
一人当たり10倍ものお肉を食べるように
なりましたん
今の時点で
畜産が排出する温室効果ガスは
送料の15%にもなります
これは地球上に走っている
すべての家庭用自動車が排出する量に匹敵
するんです
今後自動車が排出する温室効果ガスの量は
減るって予想されているので
肉食が
車よりも深刻な環境破壊の原因になる日は
もうすぐそこにあるんです
僕らはまだまだ何3もできてないんです
じゃあ
僕らに一体何ができるのでしょうか
今日から皆で b がになりましょう
って言ってもそんな簡単にはできませんよ
ね
私も
実は完全なビーガンではありません
では先ほどの夕景のデータをもう一度見て
みましょう
10年で約17%
1人あたりのお肉の消費量は減りました
ベジタリアンビーガンの総人口は約3%
増えました
つまり
彼らのおかげでをニックの消費量は3%
くらい減ったわけですよね
では消費が減った分の残りのこの14%は
どこから来たんでしょうか
答えは簡単ですよね
b がいいベジタリアンではない人が
お肉を食べる量を減らしたんです
例えば
世界でこの14%を減らすことができれば
世界中のすべての飛行機を止めるのと同じ
だけのインパクトを得られるんです
そしてこの14%は
1/7
ちょうど
1週間のうちの1日に相当します
1週間のうち1日だけ最初子を選ぶだけで
飛行機を一切使わない生活に相当するん
です
ただ
この想像を実現するためには一つだけ問題
があります
それは
ここにいるすべての人の協力が必要だと
いうことなんです
でも
実現できれば
世界が変わるんです
僕は
4年前までヨーロッパに住んでまして
ポーランドでは妻とビーガンのレストラン
を開店しました
お店は大盛況でお持ち帰りメインのお店に
毎日300人以上が訪れるようなお店に
なりました
では
なぜ
私たちのビーガンレストランは成功できた
のでしょうか
写真を見たらわかりますよね
若い頃の僕がハンサムだったからです
というのは冗談で本当の理由はお客様の
ほとんどがヴィーガンではない方だった
からなんです
お店でよくあったんですが入ってきたお客
さんがメニューを見て生誕ソーセージと
いう商品を他の者です
多分菜食に興味のある人でないとわから
ないんですが
生誕ソーセージは生誕という六木から
とれるタンパクして作ったソーセージも時
なんです
まあビーガンレストランに本物の
ソーセージが売ってあるはずがないんです
が
とにかく明らかにそのお客様はそのことに
気付いてないんです
もしかするとビーガンレストランだって
ことにすら気づいてないのかもしれません
しょうがなく説明するとほとんどの人はま
いちど試してみるかと購入してくれます
そして
次の日にまた行ってきて
生誕ソーセージを注文してくれるんです
リーガンになるって事は出来なくても比較
的気楽にヴィーガンという選択肢を選ぶ
ことができるのです
5回集です
そこで気がつきました
世界を変えるためには
すでにヴィーガンになった人のために商品
を売ってもしょうがないんじゃないかと
いっ
今
ヴィーガンじゃない人にこそ選んでもらわ
なければいけないのではないかって言っ
約5%の人が
vegan ベジタリアンだとするとその
5%の人たちはよりグリーンな生き方へ
すでに移行してしまった人たちなんです
逆にいうと私たちのような
残りの95%の人こそが
世界を変えられるんです
もちろん
植物性の選択肢を選びやすい環境作りと
いうのは大切な要素です
uk ではそれができていたからこそ
お肉の消費量を減らせたんです
私は15年前ヴィーガンになることを決意
しました
それからの僕の夕ご飯は
コンビニで買うポテチの薄塩味の大容量
パックでした
好んでポテチを夕飯にしていたわけじゃ
なくて
コンビニで買える d ガン対応の食品は
ポテチの薄塩味ぐらいしかなかったんです
15年前に日本で時間のない若者がヴィー
ガンになるというのはこういうことでした
そして
残念ながら15年経った今でも状況は
ほとんど変わっていません
最近スーパーでよく見る
お肉を使わない新しい選択って書かれた大
外に行く商品にはなんとビーフエキスと
ゼラチンが入っていました
多部のいくつかの国を除いて
菜食という考え方はとっても取り入れつ
ないのが今たに堅実なんです
じゃあ一体どうやって修理1回菜食を選ぶ
んだよってなっちゃいますよね
その状況を変えるために
小さなビーガンビジネスが活躍するんです
4年前に日本に帰国して始めた豆乳アイス
のビジネスですが
今では各地のスーパーでお取り扱い
いただいております
そんないくつかのスーパーでは私たちの
豆乳アイスがビーガンて記載された初めて
の商品だったんです
世界が少し変わった瞬間でした
想像してみてください
そのスーパーに行く人にとって登竜アイス
という植物性の選択肢は
知りもしないし
選ぶこともできない裏メニューだったん
です
でも
今は目の前にある普通の選択肢の一つに
なったんです
どちらのレールも同じなんですが
ここまで来るのに大切なのはこの商品も
購入してくれる人がいたっていうことなん
です
例えば
お客様が私たちの投入 s を選ぶことで
世界が変わったんです
また
小さなビーガンビジネスは予想以上に
大きなインパクトを世界に与えてくれます
あなたがヴィーガンになることで植物性に
変えられる消費は
一人分ですよね
でも例えば1年5万個のアイスを売れば
その消費が与えるインパクトはもっと
もっと大きなものになります
5万個のアイスというのはあなたの人生2
回分のおやつに相当しちゃうんです
かも
たったの1年でそれだけのインパクトを
得ることができるんです
もしあなたがビーガンビジネスのお客様
だったとすれば
あなたが彼らに支払った商品代金はまた
違う植物性の商品の購入のために使われる
はずです
あなたのたった1回の洗濯が何倍もの植物
性の選択に変わるんです
あなたが選べるのは
食べ物だけじゃないんです
このカラフルでかわいい写真
子供のために割れにくいこのカップに出た
んですがこれ
プラスチックじゃないんです
武
バンブーの繊維からできた植物性のカップ
なんです
こんな選択もあるんです
私には3歳になる娘が1人います
妻と並んで世界で一番かわいい女の子なん
ですが
自分がこの2年間
コロナウルスのおかげでやりたいことが
できない世界を体験して思うんです
僕らがやりたい放題して選択の自由を満喫
するおかげで
僕らの子供たちやその子どもたちがしたい
こともできない人生を送るハメになるん
じゃないかなって
思うんです
だから
責め悌
自分にできることをやって
笑顔でバトンを渡したいんです
この人類最大の危機と戦うことは b が
にならなくてもできます
でも
ここにいる
すべての人の協力が必要不可欠なんです
もうビーガンビーガンいろんなところで
聞くし
もう嫌気がさしている人もいるんじゃない
でしょうか
でも現実を見てください
私たちはまだまだ何にも出来てないんです
あなたがたまあいえらぶその植物性の選択
はとってもポジティブな選択なんです
きっとちょっとカロリー控えめでヘルシー
デー
ついでに温室効果ガスも減らせて
動物も笑顔で
未来の子供たちまで笑顔になっちゃう
そんな
ハッピーな選択肢なんです
そしてその選択はあなたを
そして世界を変えるんです